[MUSIC PLAYING]
SACHIT EGAN: OK, everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
My name is Sach Egan.
And I'm really excited and
honored to be your host today.
A lot of folks here
in Mountain View.
So thanks for coming out.
Good afternoon to you all.
I know we've got
a lot of Googlers
tuning in around the country
and even around the world.
So good day to you as well.
I'll introduce Dr.
Hanscom in a minute.
But first I'll just
begin by telling you
that, like many folks in this
room, I suffer from back pain.
And I have for a few years.
And a few years ago, I
finally decided, hey,
I want to think about surgery.
I went to all the top clinics
throughout the Bay Area,
and every single one
recommended surgery immediately.
So I was even
scheduled, I think,
two or three times within
that same week to get surgery.
I had heard about
Dr. Hanscom's book.
And so I picked that up.
I read it in about a week.
And it immediately became a top
three favorite book all time
for me for a lot of
reasons that don't even
have to do with back pain.
So I'm sorry we're out of
the free books in the back,
but I definitely encourage
you to check it out.
So Dr. Hanscom will
talk a little bit more
about his method, which is
also available on his website
backincontrol.com.
But I should also let you
know that Dr. Hanscom is
a board certified
orthopedic surgeon
with Swedish Neuroscience
specialists based out
of Seattle.
And his work focuses complex
spine deformities and issues
in all areas of the spine.
A lot of his practice, as
he'll probably mention,
is with folks who have had
multiple previous surgeries
and are still having problems.
So he's got a really cool story
personally himself and also
in his work that he'll share.
Without further ado, a round
of applause for Dr. Hanscom,
please.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID HANSCOM: Thank you, Sach.
I want to thank you very
much for having me come up.
I met him about a
year ago, I think.
And he was not
necessarily a believer
in what we were talking
about initially.
In fact, I remember the
conversation very well.
But it's a up-and-down process.
It's not hard.
It's very consistent
with time and repetition.
You'll see pretty quickly
this is a programming issue.
That's it.
Pain originates in the brain.
I have some good news, and I
have some bad news for you.
The bad news is that probably,
I estimate, 70% of spine surgery
should never be done.
And Sach's story is
typical right now
in the American medical
culture, and it's actually
damaging people and creating
disability and pain,
not solving it.
I think the medical
profession right now
is a major factor in creating
disability and chronic pain.
The good news is that
the neuroscience research
has revealed to us the
answer to the problem.
So it turns out that chronic
pain is very solvable.
I've watched hundreds of
patients go to pain free.
These are very simple,
self-directed measures.
I'd like to introduce you to
one of my successes, Dr. Mark
Owens.
And this is his video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Broke my back in two
places, and crushed
my entire left chest in,
and punctured my lung.
Had to be medevacked
to Kalispell Medical
Center in Montana, where they
fused my spine from my thoracic
9 to lumbar 2.
The pain got worse and worse.
And I had to take more and more
opiates to control the pain.
Got so bad that I couldn't
stand it any longer.
They fused my lumber
2 to my lumbar 3.
Everything from Norco to
OxyContin, oxycodone, Ultram,
muscle relaxers, sleeping
aids because I couldn't sleep,
and the pain wouldn't go away.
You become socially
isolated by your pain
because people don't want
to see you suffer like that.
Pain probably went from
7 to 10 all the time.
The times it was so bad
I couldn't stand it,
I would just--
frankly, I got to a point
where I wanted to die.
It was--
- Wow.
- Well, finally, I went to a
surgeon in Spokane, Washington.
And they breezed into
the room and said
they'd look at my
charts and everything.
And the only thing that
was going to do me any good
was [LAUGHS] what he called
the Blue Plate Special.
He said, it's going
to take two surgeries.
It'll take probably at least a
full day and probably two days.
And we got to break
your back in two places.
We're going to clean out all the
stenoses in your spinal canal
and in your nerve root canals,
and on, and on, and on.
In the end, he said we're going
to fuse you from your collar
bone to your hips.
And I said, but I'm--
he said, it's not a good option.
But he said it's the only
one that will work for you.
Your back's a mess.
I need another opinion.
And so I got an
appointment with Dr. David
Hanscom at Swedish Medical in
Seattle and went to see him.
He said I see
nothing in your spine
that would cause
the pain you feel.
It's like the phantom
wound syndrome.
Amputees often
feel the same pain
after a limb that
is giving them pain
is amputated as they did
before they lost the limb.
And it's, again, the
rewiring of the brain.
He said, what I'm
pioneering, along
with some other
physicians, a program that
will provide an alternative to
having yet more spinal fusions.
And he explained that only
around 15% to 30%, at the most,
of spinal fusions are ever
successful in alleviating pain,
even over the near term,
let alone the long term.
And so he said, I would
like you to try my program.
I said, well, what
does it consist of?
And he said, well, the
first thing you can do
is read my book on the subject.
But he said, immediately,
you can start what
we call expressive writing.
And I said, well, what is that?
And he said, well, you sit
down 15 minutes in the morning
and 15 minutes at night
and you write down
every negative thought you have
about anything in long hand,
and you tear it up.
And you throw it away.
And I said, what?
[LAUGHING]
First of all, I said, that
sounds like snake oil.
I was really honest about it.
I said, I'm a career scientist.
And I'm taught to be
a critical thinker,
and by nature, skeptical anyway.
So I frankly think this
sounds like snake oil.
And he said, wait and think
what you want, he said politely.
But he said, you can always
be filleted like a salmon.
[LAUGHING]
And he said, there'll be plenty
of surgeons who will do that,
but I won't.
And he said, or you can try this
technique and the whole program
eventually.
I said to my friend, this
really sounds unbelievable.
And I said, like the doctor
said, I can always be filleted.
I'll just try it.
So we drove down the coast from
Seattle and stayed in a motel
at night.
And that night, I
actually did some
of this so-called
creative writing.
And I woke up the next
morning, and the pain
I had been feeling, which--
maybe I should back up a little.
When you live with
pain like this,
it's like you have
a leech attached
to your body or a monkey on your
back that you can't get rid of.
It's always there.
You're always thinking about it.
You don't realize,
but it preoccupies
every aspect of your being.
I woke up that morning after
doing this first session
of creative writing.
And the first thing I
noticed is that I didn't
have that monkey, that leech.
And at first, I'd
forgotten I'd even
done the negative writing,
or the creative writing,
the night before.
And I thought what's
going on here?
This is great.
It still hurts.
But it's nothing like it was.
To make a long story short,
after another 24 hours,
I was 85% pain
free, 85% pain free.
And today, what, three
years later more or less,
yes, I have pain.
But it's pain that's easily
controllable with a Tylenol.
And sometimes I'll go
through three weeks or more
without even taking a Tylenol.
And I'm living a reasonably
normal life, a fairly active
life-- riding horses,
chainsawing and cutting wood,
again, doing physical things.
[ENGINE ROARS]
And they do make my
back uncomfortable.
But I don't have this
debilitating, crippling pain.
Basically, by visiting Dr.
Hanscom, I got my life back.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID HANSCOM: I mean,
he had chronic pain
for nine solid years.
He had sought every
imaginable cure possible.
He had seen over 30 physicians.
He had two high level
surgeons recommend a fusion
from his neck to his pelvis.
The complication rate of
that operation is about 70%
with half of those being major.
The chance of actually solving
his pain with that surgery
is about 20% to 25%.
So within six weeks,
he was pain free.
He and I have become good
friends along with my wife.
And he's fine.
He lives a normal life.
And if any of us did half the
work that he did at age 72,
our backs would be killing us.
He's fine.
So visualize what his
life would have been like
if he'd had that 12 hours of
surgery, high dose narcotics.
It would have been
a big problem.
So the purpose of my
talk today is to show you
that this is not magic.
This is not a belief system.
This is basically every human
being has their own capacity
to heal, every one of us.
From an evolutionary standpoint,
that would make sense, right?
The key is Mark somehow quickly
found his capacity to heal.
I hear this story all the time.
This is not an unusual story.
I've watched hundreds
and hundreds of patients
go to pain free, not
managing the pain,
but actually solving the pain.
So it is my belief--
and I'm sort of a technophobe.
I have to tell you this.
But I believe that one of
the most basic needs that
makes us human is to be
in charge of our destiny
with a sense of worth.
Successfully treating patients
suffering from chronic pain
requires reconnecting them with
their vision and their purpose
in life.
When you're in chronic
pain and suffering,
you become completely
disconnected.
So what happened to Mark?
So as a physician, when we
walk into the office, when
we give lectures ever
since I've been a resident,
there is quote,
"the ideal patient."
That means they're employed.
They're not on disability.
They're motivated.
They're smart.
They're intelligent.
He was all of those.
OK?
What happened?
And so what we do as
surgeons-- we think,
well, we can figure
this out in the clinic.
But remember, we're
on a volume schedule.
We're in a busy clinic.
We have 10 to 15 minutes,
maybe half an hour at the most.
And remember, two surgeons made
a diagnosis, a recommendation,
for a 12-hour surgery on the
first visit, the first visit.
OK?
That's a big deal.
Sach had recommendations
for surgery for back pain.
Were this on the first
visit also many times?
And often patients come
to me saying, well,
their surgeons really had an
urgency to do this operation.
They try to sign them up
right there in the office.
So the research has two
papers-- this is one of them--
where surgeons
actually-- it's been
documented that surgeons have a
limited ability to assess risk.
So the DRAM is a risk
assessment score--
Depression, Anxiety, which
is called somatization, where
you can't focus on your body.
So they gave this test to
a 125 orthopedic patients
prospectively.
And they identified
54 patients at risk.
And 35 of those patients
were actually distressed.
So then they asked
the surgeons to rate
their patients
about how much risk
this person was, they were
correct 26% of the time.
That's it.
And it didn't matter if
you're a medical student
or a senior attending.
They couldn't tell in
clinic who was at risk.
Couldn't do it.
So with Mark, what the
physicians didn't see
is that he had been in
Africa for 23 years.
He was very idealistic.
He went off into the
wilderness with his wife,
without even a gun.
The animals were so
wild that they had never
even seen a human being.
But he's idealistic.
He didn't understand the risk.
So the corruption he was
dealing with with the poachers
was unbelievable.
It went all the way to the top.
He's flying helicopters and
airplanes without navigation.
He had bad weather.
His wife never knew if he
was coming back or not.
And he had three
assassination attempts.
That's stress.
Then he came home and
bought a 700-acre ranch
and created a preserve for
grizzly bears and wolves,
which, of course,
didn't make him
incredibly popular with the
local ranchers, et cetera.
So stress continued.
But see, for someone
like Mark and myself,
and I'm guessing most of
the people in this room,
the stress is just
what you do, right?
I mean, isn't it
one of our badges
of honor that we just do stress?
So Mark didn't think that
was a problem except it's
been documented over
and over and over
again, over 100
years by the way,
that your body doesn't lie.
So even though
you intellectually
suppress the stress and
keep plowing forward--
you're tough.
You're resilient.
You can take it.
Again, that's a badge of honor,
particularly for surgeons.
We're suppressing
things like crazy.
And our body is
creating symptoms.
So I want to explain to you the
basic neurophysiology before I
go into the rest of this story
about what happened to Mark.
As I [INAUDIBLE] the neural
system as a junction box.
And every one of us in
this room, every second
is interpreting sensory input
to figure out what's going on--
the temperature, the shape
of the chair, the doors.
The only reason your brain
says that's a chair--
I'm sorry.
The only reason you
recognize that's a chair
is your brain's taking visual
signals, unscramble those.
And said that's a chair.
Well, that's a chair too.
That's a different chair.
So your brain is comparing
everything every second.
Same thing with pain.
This is not painful only because
my brain says it's not painful.
So the sum total of
the nervous system I
call the junction box,
so all these senses--
our vision, touch,
feel, sound, taste,
smell, with the
obvious various organs.
But there's nothing about your
nose that can smell anything.
If you disconnect the
nose from the brain,
they're just receptors.
That's it.
Your brain has to
unscramble the signals.
There's also another sensation
we don't think about much.
It's called interoception,
where if your stomach's full,
bladder's full,
et cetera, you're
body's also sensing
those sensations also.
The sum total of
these every second
is competing for attention.
On the other side,
there's going to be
a total of either pleasant,
neutral, or unpleasant.
And if it's
pleasant, your body's
going to secrete reward
chemicals like oxytocin,
serotonin, dopamine, the value
type drugs, the GABA drugs.
And if it's unpleasant, your
body is going to be tight,
tense, trying to avoid danger.
It's going to secrete
adrenaline, cortisol,
endorphins, histamines,
different stress chemicals.
Then you feel anxiety.
When we feel the positive
drugs, you feel relaxed, right?
It's not just I feel relaxed.
You actually feel relaxed.
When you feel the
unpleasant chemicals,
you actually feel anxiety.
Therefore, anxiety is
simply a chemical reaction
to the environment.
That's it, end of the story.
The reason it's so critical to
understand anxiety is simply
chemical response
to the environment
is that the unconscious brain,
which every living creature
has, is a million times
stronger than the human brain,
than the consciousness.
The unconscious brain is
a million-to-one ratio
of unconscious reactions
to the conscious brain.
So you can't stop it.
You can't control it.
So anxiety's part of
an unconscious survival
reflex that you can't control.
What
Happens is your body, they
way your brain's programmed
evolutionary-wise is that your
behavior is governed in a way
where you stay in a range where
you're not looking at bright
lights--
that was not--
that was a mistake.
Or you're not putting
your hand on hot stoves
because your body
says that's a danger.
So the nociceptive system,
or the pain system,
actually keeps you out of pain.
It doesn't produce pain, OK?
So that's why the
whole behavior's
gauged around sensory input.
So why is it so persistent?
OK, you avoid the
behaviors, et cetera.
You stay in a neutral range.
Why is it so persistent?
So the problem is that--
Shakespeare may have been
the first neuroscientist,
where he pointed out, "There
is nothing either good or bad,
but thinking makes it so."
So humans have a major
problem called consciousness.
We're the only species
to have consciousness.
The recent neuroscience
research the last two
years has been stunning
because what it shows
is that thoughts go to the
same area of the brain,
you get the same
chemical response.
So pleasant thoughts give
you reward chemicals.
You feel relaxed.
Unpleasant thoughts give
you unpleasant chemicals
and anxiety.
But there's a major problem.
You can't escape your thoughts.
So no matter who
you're talking to,
people say, I'm not anxious.
And actually, that was me
until I was 38 years old.
I'm not anxious.
Because you are so good at
masking it, and not recognizing
it, and not acknowledging it
that we think it's not there.
Every living
creature has anxiety.
Again, thoughts are a problem.
So we separate the thoughts.
They get worse as we get older.
Again, it's a programming issue.
We have all sorts of masking
behaviors like addictions,
and one of my favorite
ones is being a workaholic.
And I like to think
that's not an addiction.
I told my daughter what it is.
Look, I'm not a workaholic.
She goes, really?
I go, yeah.
I said, I really,
really enjoy what I do.
And she looked at me and
goes, well, every addict
likes their drug.
So OK, OK, touché.
There you go.
Nothing like having kids, right?
And then suppressing
is what I did.
That's how I became a
major spine surgeon.
I went to one of the top spine
fellowships in the world.
I didn't have anxiety.
I didn't get there
by having anxiety.
I'd get there by suppressing it
at the level you can't imagine,
and just bring it on.
And I'm guessing a lot of people
in this room have the same--
I use the word gunner
mode-- of just bring it on.
Right?
I can take this.
The problem is with repetition,
whether you suffer, suppress,
or mask, you get this repetition
going where these pathways
or circuits become
programmed in your brain
and they become permanent.
So it's just like
riding a bicycle.
Once you know how
to ride a bicycle,
how do you unlearn
how to ride a bicycle?
The skill can drop down
with disuse, but all of us
know how to ride a bicycle that
learned how to ride a bicycle.
Then the pain circuits are
reinforced with repetition.
There is a book I have people
read called "The Talent
Code," which is about artists,
athletes, and musicians.
With deep repetition,
you actually
learn neurological
circuits that are repeated.
But there's very
specific repetitions
over very specific moves.
It's how you learn genius.
So pain pathways are like that
in that they're very specific.
They're coming from
one part of the body.
The repetition is very fast.
So they become reinforced and
permeate very quickly, much
faster than a professional
athlete or musician learning
a skill.
And so they get reinforced
with repetition.
It's a programming problem.
So then you have a
situation now where
you can't escape your thoughts.
If somebody has a
different approach,
let me know, between suffer,
suppressing, and masking.
I've actually asked
audiences for decades,
and not gotten an
answer to that.
That's all we know how to do.
So what happens is, you're in
a continuous chemical assault.
The research terms called
"Unpleasant Repetitive
Thoughts," URTs.
So what's happening is
that everybody in this room
is under a greater or lesser
degree of an adrenaline storm.
We're being assaulted by
our own body chemistry.
And it gets worse
as you get older.
So then the problem
becomes even worse
because what would
happen to your anxiety
if you held your
hand over a stove?
It would go up, right?
And what would you do?
OK.
So what would happen to your
anxiety if I took your hand
and grabbed it and forced you
to hold it over the stove?
What would be your
next reaction?
Yeah, you would be angry, right?
So it turns out that anxiety
and anger are the same thing.
So it's a survival response.
The antidote to
anxiety is control.
You either control a situation,
or avoid it to control it,
anxiety assault. When
you're trapped by anything,
your body kicks in more
chemistry to solve the problem.
So basically, anger is
anxiety on steroids.
It's just it cranked
up the body chemistry.
So we're trapped by our
thoughts, a problem.
Then you get trapped by
your pain, another problem.
Both are equally a problem.
And what happens--
Dr. Sarno years ago
called this the rage.
And what happens,
your body is really
full of stress chemicals.
I'm using just adrenaline as
one of the representations
of the stress chemicals
because we all know
what adrenaline is all about.
But you have this really
high level of adrenaline
by being trapped by anything.
Circumstances, finances,
relationships, pain, thoughts,
whatever they are,
when you're trapped,
your body's cranked up.
Right?
So what happens is like driving
your car down the freeway
in a low gear,
second or third gear.
Your engine, your RPMs
are 5,000, 6,000 7,000.
You're driving down the freeway.
What happens?
It's going to break down.
So what happens
in the human body
is that every organ
system is now bathed
in a chemical environment.
And what happens is that
there's over 30 symptoms
of a cranked-up nervous system.
This is probably a
conservative list--
migraine headaches,
tinnitus, burning sensations
around the body, anxiety/panic
attacks, insomnia, depression,
PTSD, chronic tendinitis,
obsessive thought patterns,
irritable bowel syndrome,
obsessive compulsive disorder,
acid reflux, different back
pains, neck pains, chest pains,
skin rashes, itchiness in
the scalp, tension headaches,
heart sensations, eating
issues, and spastic bladder.
This is not a complete list.
But I just want you to stop for
a second to think about this.
OK, your body's cranked up.
You're trapped by your thoughts.
You're trapped by your pain.
You're trapped by your job.
Whatever it is you're trapped
by, you're not very happy.
So the chemical consequences
of being trapped are high.
Remember, each organ system
secretes its own chemicals.
Each organ system's going
to respond in its own way.
That's why there's
so many symptoms.
So what happened to Mark?
OK, so normally, it sounds
like it'd be operational.
He broke his back.
He got thrown from a horse.
He almost froze to death the
night before, et cetera, right?
So it sounds like, well,
you know chronic pain could
be sort of logical, right?
No?
Big injury, big surgery.
So I do this surgery every week.
The normal post-operative
course is two days
of misery, a week in between.
By two weeks, the surgical pain
is gone, and by three months,
people are fine.
So you see the bruising on his
side there from broken ribs.
He's got a nicely
healed surgical scar.
So if this had happened
20 years earlier,
the chances of him
going into chronic pain
would have been almost zero.
This is not the normal
post-operative course.
So what happened?
So there's a paper out of
Chicago, which was fascinating.
It was published in 2013.
They took a group of volunteers.
They did these research
MRI scans on the brain.
They found out
that with back pain
that there's a certain part
of the brain that lights up
every time, consistent.
It's called the
nociceptive center.
So they took patients,
or volunteers,
who had back pain for
less than two months.
And they saw that the pain
center lit up like it should.
Then they took people
who had chronic back
for more than 10 years, and
the pain center was quiet.
There's no activity in the
pain center on these people
with chronic back pain.
Guess where the center
of activity was?
There's an emotional center.
And it completely shifted
from the emotional center--
sorry-- from the pain center
to the emotional center
in about 12 months.
It happened to every
patient, every time.
So we all know about
phantom limb pain,
which is fascinating.
And from medical school
on, it's been sort of
glossed over in my training.
This is a big deal.
I'm an orthopedic surgeon.
I've done many amputations.
It's sort of a disturbing
process to take a limb
and put it into a bucket.
So you know where the
pain's coming from.
It's completely gone.
Over half the patients feel the
leg, and they feel the pain.
What's wrong with that picture?
That's a big deal.
So what happens is that
the pain is still there,
with the back
pain, for instance.
But again, it can happen
in any part of the body.
The pain is still there,
but it's a different driver.
So instead of being
the pain center,
it's now the emotional center.
The other thing I
illustrate a lot with
is that when you turn a light
switch on, where's the light?
It's at the light.
It's not at the switch.
Right?
So when the pain
center in the brain
is turned on, whether it's from
an emotional source in the pain
center, the pain is going to
be here, not in your brain.
So we know there's plenty of
risk factors for poor outcomes.
There is younger
age, being female,
the length of the pain,
the severity of the injury,
anxiety, depression,
catastrophizing, fear
avoidance, high dose narcotics.
All those are major risk--
oh, sleep, that's a huge one.
Those are all major risk factors
for poor surgical outcomes.
And I've known that
for over 30 years.
This has been in the medical
literature for over 60 years.
It's been there a long time.
We know this.
From medical school
on, we're told,
if you take a patient
who's stressed out--
they don't talk about the
body chemistry, by the way.
By they way, I'm just curious.
How people learned about
adrenaline in high school?
Can you raise your hands?
I'm just curious.
OK.
So that, to me, that's
why I'm a little perplexed
that the medical
system has missed this
because when you're under
stress for any reason,
your body's full of adrenaline.
So the research paper out of
Baltimore showed that only 10%
of orthopedic surgeons
and neurosurgeons
were assessing
these risk factors
before they did surgery.
And guess what?
The outcomes were
all over the map.
In fact, the outcomes
were very bad
when these risk factors
weren't addressed.
So the definition of
chronic pain, now--
this is from Chicago,
but neuroscience centers
around the world have come
to this common definition
that chronic pain is an
"imbedded memory that
becomes linked with more
and more life experiences,
and the memory can't be erased."
And there's another saying
that neuroscientists
have that neurons that fire
together wire together.
So if you have back
pain when you climbed
a certain set of steps,
again, every time you
climb those steps, your
brain links that with pain.
So this is not
psychological, this
is simply a direct link
with a chemical response.
It has nothing to
do with psychology.
So again, I'm going to ask
people to raise their hands.
How many people
are given the idea
that surgery is the
definitive solution?
Is that a common belief
amongst this crowd?
A little bit.
So in doctors, it is.
I mean, when I first started
my training for the first seven
or eight years, I felt
like as a surgeon,
you've suffered for a long time.
I felt obligated,
literally obligated,
to find a solution
to your problem.
What else do you do?
You've tried everything else.
And so no matter
what happens, you're
going to try to find a
reason to solve the problem.
Right?
Well, really?
So here's some of the data.
So the problem is, you're
using a structural solution
for a neurological diagnosis.
You're way off target.
It can't work.
It just can't work.
And guess what?
It doesn't work.
So the analogy I like to use is
that I'm going to the dentist
with a cavity that's painful.
You know where the problem is.
The dentist either
pulls the tooth
or fills the cavity or crown.
Problem solved.
Right?
Happens almost 100% of the time.
But if you go to the
dentist with mouth pain,
and you don't know
where the problem is,
and you start filling
teeth, pulling teeth,
whatever, the chances of
success are very, very low.
With back pain, we
actually don't know
where the pain coming from.
We know where the pain's
coming from literally
15% of the time, 1-5.
So you start doing these
big procedures on something
that you don't know
what the solution is.
Spine surgery has a
terrible reputation.
And it actually is deserved.
So surgery works extremely
well for a structural problem.
I do lots of surgery.
We have a high success rate,
but I can see what we're doing.
You can't fix something
you can't see.
What I didn't know
until a few years ago--
and this data has actually
been around for a while--
is that when you have chronic
pain in your nervous system,
and you do surgery in
another part of the body,
you can create chronic
pain in the new body part.
So let's take our
hernia repair, which is
a very straightforward surgery.
And say you've had chronic
neck pain for five years.
The hernia goes beautifully.
You can induce chronic
pain at the hernia site
between 5% to 60% of the time.
And up to 4% of the time,
it can become permanent.
Surgeons aren't taught this.
I wasn't.
Patients aren't really
told that chronic pain
can be a complication of a
simple, well-performed surgery.
And it's a big deal.
So in defense of
the surgeons, when
we talk about a
Blue Plate Special,
that's all we're trained to do.
And we're not really
taught about chronic pain.
We're not taught
about sleep, stress.
Actually, we sort
of know about it.
But then surgeons, the way
we become compartmentalized
as specialists, we're
responsible for this part
of the problem, but not the
whole part of the problem.
And so there's been
a real disconnect.
So the physicians
are well-intentioned,
but the business of medicine
has made it very difficult
for us to actually take
time to talk to and listen
to the patients.
So with Mark's situation, I will
admit that that first visit,
I did not know his background.
But it was easy for him
because I never, ever
make a surgical decision
on the first visit, ever.
I don't know you.
You don't know me.
I don't know the circumstances.
The last 10 years,
I have learned a lot
that when people
are under stress,
the body chemistry
changes, and symptoms
start arising that
had not arisen before.
So with Mark, it was
actually pretty simple
because he did not
have a surgical lesion.
How many people here have been
told that degenerative disc
disease is a problem?
Anybody heard that?
OK.
So we don't know where back pain
comes from most of the time.
But we actually know--
it's been well-documented--
that arthritis,
bulging disc, herniated
disc, degenerative
disc actually don't cause pain.
They are not a source of pain.
Is that surprising to anybody?
It's a problem because
your spine becomes stiffer.
But it's been well-documented
that it is not
a source of pain yet.
It is a reason to do surgery
on over 500,000 people per year
right now.
They estimate by
2020, it will be
up over a million people per
year getting spine fusions.
So with Mark, it was simple.
He's got some disc degeneration.
He had some arthritis
here, here, here, and here.
Here's his rods down
in through here.
Let me just point up to there.
There's no real--
Anyway, he has his
arthritis on left side.
He's got some
narrowing of the disc.
And that's fine.
So that's a normal
spine for somebody who's
68 years old, flat-out normal.
OK, if anyone of you had a MRI
scan of your spine, especially
those without pain, you're
going to have degeneration.
It is not a source of pain.
So Mark's case was
pretty simple for me.
So I'm just picking
one study out of many.
This was done in 2006
out of Stanford here.
They took patients who had
an unstable spine, actually
moving back and forth
about 4 millimeters, what
surgeons consider a source
of pain, and they fused them.
They found out the
success rate was 72%
at two years, which, to me,
is lower than it should be.
To me, it should be 100%.
But then they did
this disc study,
where they inject a
dye into the disc.
If the disc was painful,
then they would fuse it.
They did one level fusions.
They found out the success
rate was 27% percent.
Other papers show 15%, 22%, 24%.
There's not one
paper, not one paper
that says that a fusion
works for back pain.
Not one.
Surgery now is a $13
billion a year industry.
So I stopped doing surgery
in 1993 for back pain.
I quit doing fusion
for back pain in 1993.
But I didn't know what to do.
What do I do?
So I was a surgeon.
I was trained to do fusions.
I felt guilty if I didn't find
a reason to do the fusion.
And so what happened, I
learned it the hard way.
So I became a chronic pain
sufferer for over 15 years.
That's how this book
evolved was my own ordeal
with chronic pain.
And I had 16 of those
symptoms I mentioned before.
I had ringing in my ears,
burning feet, skin rashes,
itching scalp,
insomnia, anxiety, OCD.
You name it, I had it.
I had no idea what
was going on, no idea.
And nobody could tell me.
So I became desperate.
I had no hope.
I didn't know what was going on.
And by pure luck, I ran
across this recommendation
by Dr. David Burns-- here
at Stanford, by the way.
And he and I have become
pretty good friends.
And Jeff has been nice enough
to introduce me to him again.
David Burns wrote a book
called "Feeling Good."
And David Burns said
to start writing.
So I started writing
his technique.
And I initially thought it was
the book, but I later found out
was actually the writing.
There's over 300 research
papers that document
that expressive writing,
different forms of it, work.
They break up all
sorts of pain cycles.
Performance goes up.
Grades go up.
Asthma improves.
Skin heals faster.
It's unbelievable.
And nobody knows why it works.
But there's way
more data on this
than there is on spine surgery.
So basically, it's
on my website.
You simply write down your
thoughts and tear them up.
And you tear them
up for two reasons.
First of all, you can't
not control your thoughts,
but you can separate from them.
You've heard the philosophers
say for centuries that you're
not your thoughts, and they
use meditation to separate.
I call this mechanical
meditation, where
you write down your thoughts.
There's a space between
you and your thoughts.
That space is now connected
with vision and feel, which is
part of the unconscious brain.
And the reason why you rip
them up is for two reasons.
One is to write with freedom.
And by the way, it can be
positive or negative thoughts.
Most of the research has been
done on negative thoughts,
but it doesn't really matter.
But the other reason
that you rip them up,
which is more important,
is that if you
want to analyze and
fix these things,
where is your attention?
It's on your thoughts.
So I still do it,
20 years later.
If I quit doing my
writing exercises,
the first thing that happens
is my wife asks me, she goes,
honey, have you been
doing your writing?
[LAUGHTER]
Because we tend both
to get a little bit
snappy when we don't do
it because we get anxious.
And I don't sleep as well.
These little skin rashes pop up.
So about two weeks almost to
the day, if I quit my writing
exercises, which I
do maybe one or two
minutes is all it takes--
it's like brushing your teeth.
It's really simple.
So with neuroplasticity,
you want
to do awareness, separation,
then you want to redirect.
It's like directing a river
into different channels.
You want to come off the pain
circuits into a different set
of circuits.
So it's things like
visualization, good food,
good wine, good friends.
Meditation, that's the
re-visualization tool.
So you have a situation now
where you have chronic pain.
You have an adrenalized
nervous system.
You can't escape your thoughts.
Surgery is not going to work.
These are permanent pathways.
Doesn't sound that good, right?
And the harder
you try to fix it,
your attention's on the
pathways, it makes it worse.
So it is a solvable problem.
But you have to first understand
the traditional ways of solving
it can't and don't work.
So I'll just give you
couple of principles.
So why is chronic
pain so hard to treat?
Well, again, we're using
a structural intervention
for a neurological problem.
So we're treating symptoms.
We're not treating
the real cause.
We're doing surgery,
injections, medications.
And what's fascinating
and disturbing
both is that most
of interventions
we do for chronic pain have
been documented not to work.
There's no data supporting
epidurals for back pain.
facet rhizotomies for back pain.
We know about opioids.
That's a big problem.
So everything we do in the
medical profession right now
has actually been
documented not to work,
including spine surgery.
We don't have the
diagnosis correct.
Even though that neuroscience
has shown us a diagnosis,
this has not penetrated
mainstream medical thinking.
And the other
problem is that we've
been throwing simplistic
random solutions
to a complicated problem.
I know everybody in this room is
used to dealing with complexity
and trying to solve complexity.
Right?
I had a friend of
mine introduced me
to complexity theory.
And I'll admit, I
only know the term.
But chronic pain's complicated.
There's multiple things
that affect chronic pain.
So we're randomly throwing this
at it, throwing this at it,
and it can't work.
So it's like fighting
a forest fire.
It takes multiple strategies
to contain this blaze.
Right?
A fire hose isn't
going to do it.
Bulldozers alone
aren't going to do it.
This is a multi-pronged
approach to solve it.
And everything counts.
So what happens with
this relentless thought
assault, routinely
adrenalized, we
have these unpleasant thoughts,
the adrenalized nervous
system--
and the two strategies
or two principles
behind solving the problem
is to simply de-adrenalize
the nervous system.
So everybody, just
sit back for a second
and drop your shoulders.
Just feel the chair you're in.
That's it.
So what you've done is you've
simply switched sensory input.
Instead of being
on racing thoughts
or unpleasant
sensations, you just
went to a different sensation.
That's it, three
to five seconds,
I call it active meditation
to decrease the adrenaline
just a little bit.
You do it repetitively
throughout the day.
It keeps the adrenaline
levels coming down.
It eventually becomes
somewhat automatic.
I like to do it more as
my personal commitment.
And the other principle
is called neuroplasticity,
which remember,
I said awareness,
separation, redirecting, again,
like redirecting your river
to a different channel.
And that's awareness,
separation, reprogramming.
And so that's the
second principle.
The third one is shifting.
So pain pathways are permanent.
You can't solve them.
So the [INAUDIBLE]
allows you to separate,
and then you redirect so you
can shift onto play pathways.
And those of you in chronic
pain probably, I suspect,
the life isn't
nearly as much fun
as it used to be before
you had chronic pain.
Right?
It's a problem.
So you can't solve chronic
pain because if you
quit using those
pathways, they start
to atrophy just like any skill.
If you start reinforcing the
creative, enjoyable pathways,
they start to grow.
At some tipping point, people
come off these pathways
and go onto the
pleasant pathways.
It's very, very consistent.
So what we do, we tend to run
from pain. tend to fight it,
whatever.
And the essence
of the problem is
the more you fight and
try to treat chronic pain
and just try to
conquer it-- again,
it's a million-to-one ratio.
You can't do it.
You actually give it more
neurological attention.
And it's a problem.
So the essence of the solution
is becoming comfortable--
again, a learned skill--
with uncomfortable sensations,
whether they're thoughts,
anxiety, anger.
You've got to be OK being angry.
You got to be OK being anxious.
And you just train your
body just not to react.
You notice, as you start
decreasing the adrenaline,
the body's nerve
conduction improves.
So the anxiety
drops dramatically.
That's the most fun part of
this process, by the way.
And then the pain
starts to improve.
So we call this
the ring of fire.
We're trained to avoid anxiety.
So the red ring represents
anger, anxiety, disgust,
vulnerability, et cetera.
And we hate it.
This is a survival
center feeling.
So what we do is we
spend a lifetime trying
to achieve, accomplish, own,
experience, whatever it is,
to stay in this blue ring
to avoid the red ring.
So look at this when you go
home-- it's on the website--
and think about it.
I realized at one point,
I spent my entire life
in the blue ring.
And I would touch the red
ring and pop right out
into the blue ring.
I was so much in the blue
ring, I actually didn't even
know the red ring existed.
So when I, by force, was forced
to go through the red ring
into the center is you become
comfortable with uncomfortable
feelings, where you end up is in
the green, which is the center,
safe, content.
And you're not
burning adrenaline.
And I probably have triple the
energy I had in high school,
and I had plenty back then
because I'm not burning
adrenaline all the time.
So we're taught you
can have it all.
Right?
We have all these opportunities.
And the problem is you
cannot run your mind.
So what we are taught
to do is that we're
trying to make
ourselves better people,
and it's like climbing
a huge mountain.
At the top of this mountain,
there's a better you.
And so you learn.
You become enlightened.
You meditate.
You do mindfulness,
all this type of stuff,
but there's no top
to the mountain.
You tell me you have an ideal
picture of who you should be
or could be in your
brain, and you're
climbing and climbing and
climbing, but there's no top.
So what you do, as
[INAUDIBLE],, if you just
picture a bunch of balloons
tied to a railing, what
the tools do, they
cut the strings.
And pretty soon, you get to
take off, which takes no energy.
And where do you go?
There's no place to go.
You don't have to go any place.
You're just there.
And what happens, you
get to be creative again.
Pain becomes sort
of a distant memory.
And you're free.
So you can't solve chronic pain.
These are permanent,
unconscious survival skills,
but you can move into
a different realm.
So the details are all in
my book, "Back in Control--
a Surgeon's Roadmap
Out of Chronic Pain."
And I learned this the hard
way, literally a millimeter
at a time.
Then the website I
recommend, actually,
people hop on first and
just go to stage one.
And you'll see a sequence that,
over the next six to 12 months,
as you start walking
through this sequence,
it's not a fixing process.
It's not a formula.
It's not a one, two,
three, and you're fixed.
But it's a set of concepts,
a framework, that breaks pain
into its different parts.
It allows you to address
each part on your own terms.
You take control.
And there's some tipping points,
and then we go to pain-free.
And it's very, very consistent.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate your time.
[APPLAUSE]
SACHIT EGAN: You have time
for a Q&A, right, Dr. Hanscom?
DAVID HANSCOM: Pardon?
SACHIT EGAN: You have time
for a question and answer?
DAVID HANSCOM: Absolutely.
SACHIT EGAN: OK.
I'll just kick things off.
I've got one from New York.
DAVID HANSCOM: OK.
SACHIT EGAN: And the question
is, "Does your approach work
for all kinds of back pain?
And if not, can
you give examples
where it doesn't work as well?"
DAVID HANSCOM: So
we found out that--
I used to think that surgical
lesions like spinal stenosis
and bone spurs had to
have surgery to solve it.
It turns out that
it doesn't matter
where the pain comes from.
So if it's structural problem
or not a structural problem,
it doesn't matter.
So the answer is yes, it
works for any type of pain.
What we do, though, we do what
we call a pre-hab process.
And if you're my
patient, look, maybe we
do surgery on your back.
We're going to calm
you down first.
And our outcomes have
been spectacular.
So yeah, the
solution-- so actually,
now, almost 100 patients
that were on the schedule
to have surgery, they came
in for their final visit,
they canceled their surgery.
The pain went away.
So that has been
completely unexpected.
So it's actually been
devastating to my practice.
So it's a little
awkward at this point.
SACHIT EGAN: That's
good to hear.
I guess a follow-up
would be-- this
is something that I
haven't asked you before.
There's a certain level of
anxiety that's perhaps natural.
It's not the kind that you
would go see a therapist for,
that somebody would
say is abnormal.
DAVID HANSCOM: Right.
SACHIT EGAN: At what point
do you have a patient maybe,
and you might not want to do
surgery on them because they
don't have a problem in their
spine that warrants surgery.
You can tell that
they're anxious,
but it's an appropriate amount.
Like, do you have
something you would
say to those types of people?
DAVID HANSCOM:
Well, first of all,
if you didn't have
anxiety, you would die.
So this is not about
getting rid of anxiety.
It's not about
suppressing anxiety.
It's being comfortable to
use the cues to actually take
safe action.
So I mean, there's
no definition of when
anxiety becomes a problem.
In other words, if
it's disruptive to you,
then it's a problem.
Right?
So again, it's not trying
to solve it or control it.
It's simply letting it go.
And I talk about moving
forward with your pain, which
means anxiety.
By the way, I didn't make
this clear in the lecture.
Mental pain and physical pain
are processed the same way.
Anxiety is the pain.
OK?
So you're not trying to
get rid of it or solve it.
But as you quit
paying attention to it
and trying to do battle with
it, it simply starts to atrophy.
And so yeah, anxiety is
something that's life.
Anger's part of life.
You're not going
to get rid of that.
SACHIT EGAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, your
comments about adrenaline
makes me reall curious,
because from my experience,
I've found that
adrenaline actually
helps with the pain in the sense
that it washes it out or makes
me forget about it.
Is that because I'm on
the blue ring, let's say?
DAVID HANSCOM: Yep.
AUDIENCE: There you go.
DAVID HANSCOM: But let
me talk about that.
I mean, 20 years ago, I
had a patient come in who,
we'd talk about this process.
I didn't have a
project back then,
but I had some
sense that there's
some things going on here.
So he was an
incredibly angry guy.
Not that you're angry.
I don't know you.
But let's just take
perfectionism for a second.
All of us have high
standards, right?
We think that's the
right thing to do.
Well, the problem
is that genealogy
of anger, where you have a
situation that you blame,
that you're a victim,
and then you're angry.
So with perfectionism, which
is being self-critical,
you have perfection which
you'll never achieve.
So you're either unhappy with
the situation or yourself
of being less than perfect.
So you're always a victim,
you're always frustrated,
and you're always
angry, frustrated.
So Dr. Burns pointed
out the delta,
or the difference
between reality
and your vision of perfection--
sorry-- your vision
of perfection and reality is how
unhappy you're going to become.
So what happens
in that situation
is you're always adrenalized.
So what happens is, I used
to be quote, "successful."
Right?
I went to the top, top
level spine fellowship.
I was successful, made
money, had a beautiful house.
And the same adrenaline drug
that took me up the hill
took me right down
the other side.
It's hard to let go of because
we're used to adrenaline.
It does quote, "make us
successful" on paper.
I also have 19
medical colleagues
who died from suicide.
Doctors have double the suicide
rate of the average population.
And suicide is not a
depression response.
It's an anger response
because anger is destructive.
The ultimate act of destruction
is self-destruction.
So I can give you hundreds of
stories of most my colleagues,
of people self-destructing.
Is that successful?
So yeah, you can get a lot done
with adrenaline, and we do.
But does it give you a relaxing,
content, fulfilled life?
That's the question.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks, Doctor.
I wanted to know-- so if,
let's say, a person has
chronic pain, how to
they diagnose whether it
is structurally or mentally.
DAVID HANSCOM: So
again, this holds
for all pain, migraine
headaches, whatever it is.
So since I've taken
the pain project,
I'm hyper about
doing the work-up.
In other words, I'll make sure
it's not a tumor or infection
or something
causing the problem.
But what I'm seeing
with these patients
with surgical problems, those
weren't structural problems.
And historically, I would have
done surgery in a heartbeat,
even by my
conservative standards.
And they would have
done pretty well,
but some of them wouldn't.
So what happens-- I tease
my fellows about this--
when was last time you
saw a surgical failure
in my practice?
And they don't.
For elective surgery, we go
through this rehab process
before surgery.
Patients' outcomes
are spectacular.
We have this whole group of
patients, even with bone spurs,
that are cancelling the surgery
because their pain disappeared.
It wasn't because they
were living with the pain.
The pain actually disappeared.
So I'm actually shocked.
I had no idea.
Every time that happens,
which happens every week now,
I just shake my head.
I'm going, what's going on?
So it's been very interesting.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
coming to talk with us.
I noticed that throughout
your presentation,
at no point in
time you mentioned
the idea of physical
therapy or any form
of chiropractic intervention.
DAVID HANSCOM: Right.
AUDIENCE: I'm a big supporter
of Dr. Stuart McGill,
and I've read most of his--
DAVID HANSCOM: Who?
AUDIENCE: Dr. Stuart McGill.
DAVID HANSCOM: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and so I've
read most of his major works,
and he's very much so on
supporting and stabilizing
the spine--
DAVID HANSCOM: Right.
AUDIENCE: --and just
getting comfortable
in certain positions, and
then expanding from there.
I was curious on your
thoughts on his work,
and why you haven't been a
proponent of physical therapy.
DAVID HANSCOM: Oh, I am.
So I've picked up the
forest fire section.
Normally, when I give
this talk-- my goal today
is to create this paradigm shift
that you can heal yourself.
I hope that came through.
So it turns out that you have
to address all your variables
at once with sleep, stress,
medication management,
but physical condition is huge.
So I'm a proponent
of the weight room.
I like acupuncture,
chiropractic, physical therapy.
It's been a wonderful thing
for my physical therapists
because they do their thing,
but the book and the process
takes care of the sleep,
the stress, whatever it is.
So no, physical therapy is
a huge part of the deal.
Remember, everything works
in chronic pain a little bit,
but nothing works by itself.
So sleep could be 25%-30%.
Stress management
could be another 30%.
Physical therapy could
be another 20%-25%.
So when you start adding
these things together,
it makes a big difference.
So you're in good
physical shape.
So physical therapy,
probably for you,
is not as important as
some of these other things
that people who are
grossly out of shape.
So everybody has different,
I use the word "formula,"
because everybody is different.
So by definition,
if you're unique,
and I'm unique, which we
are, then the only person
who can solve my problem
is going to be me.
I can't get inside your brain.
So yeah, the
physical conditioning
is a huge, huge
factor in this thing.
And that's all in the book.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVID HANSCOM: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so
much for your talk.
I can confirm that taking
stress out of your life
gets rid of chronic pain.
I had lower back pain for years.
And once I started taking
out a bit stress of my life
and don't take work as
seriously, to a certain extent,
really helped me.
DAVID HANSCOM: Good.
AUDIENCE: I have
a question around
adrenalin because it's like--
the talk about adrenaline
slightly confused me
because what is the right
level of adrenaline?
Or maybe, what's the
difference between adrenaline
and dopamine?
Because for example,
if I do a sport,
I get an adrenaline rush, but
the outcome is successful.
I mean, I have a dopamine rush.
Like, what's the right balance?
Because now I'm a bit
afraid to expose myself
to too much adrenaline,
and so I don't
know what the right level is.
DAVID HANSCOM: So I wish
I had more time here.
My wife and I do workshops
together over a three or four
day period of time.
By the way, we're doing
a workshop in New York
this June 29 through July
1, a three-day workshop.
It'll be on my
website here shortly.
The reality is we don't
really know the answer
to that question.
And so the goal
here isn't trying
to control things around you.
In other words, I
put that ring of fire
out there because
what happens, you
become comfortable going back
and forth through the rings.
So the amount of
adrenaline doesn't matter.
So I probably have five
times the stress on my plate
right now than I had when
I broke 20 years ago.
So what happens is you
just train your brain
not to be adrenalized
when you deal with stress.
Because remember,
stress, by definition,
is a threat, which
is always adrenaline.
Otherwise, it wouldn't
be stress, right?
So what you do is
a lot of things
that we perceive as stress--
stress, which our
thoughts are, a lot of it
is perceived stress--
you start training your brain
just to have less adrenaline.
And so you quit avoiding stress.
You really can just
process almost anything.
And I fail.
We have some pretty
bad weeks and stuff.
So I always tell my patients,
learn how to fail well,
because these pathways
are permanent.
You're always going
to be adrenalized.
You always kick
these things back up.
But you just process them more
quickly and more efficiently.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVID HANSCOM: I guess
one last question?
AUDIENCE: Going back
to the physical side,
if you are working on
your back, whether it
be massage or physical
activity, anything
in particular that
you do recommend,
either massage-wise
or specific exercises
to strengthen the back?
DAVID HANSCOM: Yeah,
I like them both.
I mean, I think that
things like massage,
for instance, gives you a
different set of sensations.
So I think there's, first of
all, a relaxation effect which
decreases the adrenaline.
But you're also substituting
the neurological impulses
on the part of the
body that's painful.
I love the weight room.
Obviously strengthening
and conditioning helps.
It also gives you a mental
approach that's proactive,
pushing weights.
But also, I think
what you're doing,
you're substituting,
again, different impulses
from that part of the
body than pain impulses.
So the weight room
to me is a big deal,
Pilates is a big deal.
So all those things
become somatic tools.
That's what our workshops
are, by the way,
are somatic workshops,
connecting thoughts
with physical sensations.
I think that exercise is
one way of substituting
different sensations
from the pain sensations.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVID HANSCOM: Yeah.
Sach, I guess that's it.
[APPLAUSE]
So thank you.